well the one and welcome to today's
webinar titled Sarris code v2 koban 19
emergence biology and countermeasures
this webinar is part of an ongoing
coronavirus virtual webinar series I'm
Suzy Valdez elaborates and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth
now let's get started before we begin I
want to remind everyone that this event
used interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you might have during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
hearing this presentation click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your presentation screen as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free education
credit click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present to these speakers
dr. mark Dennison the director of the
division of infectious diseases at Craig
Weaver and professor of pediatrics and
professor of pathology microbiology and
immunology a professor at Vanderbilt
University for complete biography on dr.
Denison please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. Denison
marks you may begin the presentation
welcome sir
let's see this event occurring certainly
I have worked on coronaviruses since
1984 when I started my infectious
diseases fellowship in pediatric
infectious diseases and we have been
thinking about this particular event for
a long time certainly since before the
SARS epidemic actually myself and my
colleagues had been looking at the
capacity of viruses particularly a mouse
coronaviruses the changes of species
specificity at least in lab in the lab
looking at that cell culture so my work
has been focusing on the replication the
biology the evolution the the viral
proteins responsible for replication and
then targets for antivirals and we've
been working really for the last ten
years on specific development of and
preclinical testing of antivirals
including the work that was has been
done on the severe one of the the major
drugs it's in trial right now that
preclinical development was done in my
laboratory and in that of my colleague
Roth barek at the University of North
Carolina as I start I want to to let you
know who does the work and that's most
important and sometimes that gets left
out so I just wanted to point out the
people in my laboratory as a last fall
and then some that have graduated and
moved on but with particular focus on
Maria Agostini who was the graduate
student who really performed the bulk of
the work that I'll described today along
with dr. Jim Chapel
Jennifer Gribble and under krauser's who
is the lead scientist on their
antivirals program as well as everyone
else who is contributing and all of whom
are working really seven days a week
right now for the last three months to
test these antivirals against SARS Coby
- um we are we are glad that there may
be an opportunity to put to use some of
the things that we've been studying in
such detail and I wanted to spend the
time today really maybe taking you
through a little more in the details of
the biology then maybe I've seen on some
of the other talks and try to get a
feeling for why we have talked about
this virus the way we have yryr concerns
are so high and why we think it's
important
really pursue a detailed understanding
the virus biology and the targets for
antivirals with a couple exam to give
you just a couple examples of that
because of course it's not possible to
be comprehensive and certainly I'm
interested in your questions and trying
to see if we can address those as we go
okay see if I can change the slides
alright so a visit is mentioning our
collaborators of the University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill Roth barrack Amy
Simms Tim Sheehan and a Rachel Graham as
well as at Emory a Gilead Sciences
University of Alabama Birmingham and
then our funding which is all from the
from the NIH so I'm I don't have any
direct financial conflicts so we have
been in a long-term collaboration now
with Gilead and with Emory University on
compounds okay
I just put this up because I think this
isn't a surprise for anybody that's
working with coronaviruses have probably
made these same predictions but really
this is just an excerpt from one of our
grant applications in 2018 and I look
back to 2013 and 2008 and and found the
same things and basically the idea is
that the epidemics of SARS and MERS and
humans have confirmed the capacity of
coronaviruses to emerge from animal
reservoirs and cause human disease no
question and as SARS like bad viruses
are currently circulating in nature that
replicated human cells cause disease in
mice and are resistant existing
therapeutics antibodies and vaccines and
then is really been published as long as
2015 but but before that with bat SARS
like viruses and then finally with
increasing overlap of human and wild
animal ecology the potential for future
zoonotic coronavirus emergences is high
and this is actually the basis for why
we have the research funding that we
have to study this and why we've been
looking at this issue for the last
multiple years this is also this issue
of the accelerating emergence of
zoonotic
coronaviruses I I in the past I've I've
had to spend a lot of time talking about
this because no one was familiar with it
but I put this light up to give you a
sense that really even the old corona
viruses are new that is that maybe the
oldest ones that we know of are maybe
eight hundred years old in humans which
from an evolutionary perspective is very
very new to the neighborhood and then a
2 to 9 so the for know now known two of
which were identified only after the
SARS epidemic
HKU sorry el 63 HK h co v2 290 human
coronaviruses c 43 and HK you one of all
of which really have and some of which
may have only been in the last hundred
to 150 years
so so these are really new viruses and
humans it raises the issues and
questions of when does something become
an endemic virus how long does it take
when does seasonality occur i have many
strong opinions on that but i think
what's important is to look at really
the viruses that are present now SARS
since 2002 and 2004 MERS 2012 currently
and ongoing and and then are novel
coronavirus or SARS Kobe to think a
couple points here in terms of the need
for it
for antivirals and I'll get to this in a
minute these viruses are giving us
different demonstrations of the capacity
of this virus family that I hesitate to
use the word unique but it might be a
close to a good term with SARS Coby to
of a SARS in 2002 2004 as that virus
emerged why people ask me the question
why did that get controlled why did that
go away and this one seems to be
persisting and causing so much
devastation worldwide I think one of the
points was that that the original SARS
really was focused on on severe lung
disease and transmission of that virus
only occurred when someone had a
pneumonia or deep seeded lower
respiratory tract infection not allowed
for identification isolation and control
I basically say that Public Health was
successful because the virus allowed it
MERS by its MERS on the other hand
secondly is less transmissible but new
cases of MERS that are still arising in
the Arabian Peninsula and other places
still have about a thirty five percent
mortality so a less transmissible virus
both are much higher mortality which
represents a significant concern for if
that virus changed or had a significant
evolutionary adaptation that allowed it
to have more rapid data transmission
that would be a very great concern and
then Tsarskoe v2 seems to be sort of the
Swiss Army knife of emerging zoonotic
corona viruses this capacity for spread
and shed from the upper respiratory
tract from low level infection from
pre-symptomatic infection along with
such a range of infect
stillness from mild respiratory to
potentially asymptomatic disease to
really really severe profound ard yes
similar to that of SARS so it feels like
these last two were sort of a I hesitate
to say practice runs for coronaviruses
and that this virus are experiencing now
really has the potential for for really
being maintained I think just at this
point raising this issue of what will
happen with this virus in terms of
seasonality I think anyone that says
they know is is it's nonsense these are
not scientists or they're ignoring their
own data or the data that we have which
is none this is a new virus in humans
there are seven billion people with the
planet who are susceptible and so the
virus is evolutionarily appears to be in
a very happy hunting ground
in terms of humans so this virus is not
I don't believe is going anywhere and
has no need to become a seasonal virus
at this point there's no evolution I
selected pressure right it's my opinion
but that opinion is more more formed on
the basis of knowledge that this is a
new virus and we can't make comparisons
to viruses that have been around for
hundreds or thousands of years in terms
of the trends and what we would expect
the spiders to do within the first year
that it's here in humans so where does
virus come from I might have spent a lot
of time on this but I think it's
important to think about this and I've
heard it from multiple really really
good speakers and from long and others
but I wanted to sort of give a little
slightly different perspective from them
from the perspective of the virus's
capacity I think the idea there's two
different sort of models one is the
issue of host range mutations and that's
what people tend to focus on is this a
mutation that arose that suddenly made
this fire is capable well I guess when
you think about what a virus has to do
to be successful as a zoonotic pathogens
or that means emerging into humans and
becoming human disease which which is
what Tsarskoe v2 is now what does that
take well it has to be able to get into
a host it has to be able overcome a
doubt the innate immune responses were
void adaptive immune responses or
suppress them avoid physical barriers
replicate transmit or replicate to high
levels transmit be stable in the
environment in fact new hosts all of
those things suggest that a single
mutation is unlikely in contrast a
corona virus is that the data that's
emerging seems to support more the idea
that in these large diverse populations
of bats in other places that you really
have
diversity viruses some of which are
functioning maybe as specialists but
others which are emerging and and
evolving as generalists that is that
they are ready made to move into new
hosts and what they lack is opportunity
and what we're providing for them is
opportunity both by initial
opportunities for introduction into
humans and then by either the things we
did by commission or omission to provide
an environment that allows for the virus
to really exercise its its its
characteristics and qualities of
transmission spreads and disease but I
think that that's a more consistent with
what we're seeing with with the corona
viruses they emerge and this this slide
um shows this as an old phylogeny it's
not new and I've overlaid things that
aren't meant to be accurate look at
localizations with the exception of a
couple things one is if you look at the
things that are circled the blue the
blue circles or shapes that contain
multiple viruses and bt always implies
them indicates a bad virus you can see
that there's different groups and those
are the beta corona viruses and in blue
the alpha corona viruses in the green
color the ones that are circled in red
of course are the are the ones that have
humans is he can have human disease
except for the ones with the bat ones up
in the corner and then our model virus
mary hepatitis virus which is some of
the virus that we use the beta corona
viruses really seem to be where the
zoonotic viruses came from the Alpha
corona viruses and some beta corona
viruses are causing devastating diseases
in animals so that's also a place where
those could arise well what I want to
the point I wanted to make here is that
you can see the human coronaviruses are
spread out that MERS can from a
different group in SARS and that at in
the same group that SARS is in what we
call the group to be beta corona viruses
are also where the SARS Co v2 is coming
from
finally there's these other viruses up
in the right corner and I'm calling
those sort of these are the ones that we
think of as those generalists that were
already ready so these were studied in
in the Eric lab and other places and and
these viruses when they were resurrected
were shown to be able to infect cells
and culture human cells and culture
and again to be able to infect mice and
in some cases to cause some mild or more
severe disease so these are what we call
we were referring to as ready-made
pre-pandemic virus
suggesting that these generalists exist
in the population and they're really
looking for an opportunity and that's
all the think that's all they need I
will occasionally fall prey to using
anthropomorphic terminology for the
virus I try to avoid it if at all
possible because these viruses aren't
really thinking about anything I'm the
virus that's here tomorrow is the one
that was successful today so it's really
more about evolutionary fitness and
selection there isn't a goal for the
virus it's not looking for an
opportunity but when there is an
evolutionary niche that arises that
virus may be prepared to take advantage
of it okay now I want to move on to
really talk about the issue of the need
for antivirals against her own viruses
why have we been pursuing this and and I
think now it almost feels like a moot
point of course it's important to pursue
it but why have we been doing this for
the last ten years I think our real
issue was his issue of the broad
diversity of coronaviruses and bats with
demonstrated the ability to infect
animals in culture or infect cells in
culture these outbreak ready viruses
that we've known this and we've known
some other things we've known that the
failure of antibodies from one virus
core viruses to neutralize other core
viruses so human coronavirus mom
antibodies don't neutralize SARS rumors
okay animal ones from different
different animal species don't
neutralize the human ones even during
the SARS outbreak there was some
evidence that late in the later in the
infection that antibodies that were
being made with sort of vaccine designs
against the very early civet or human
strains of SARS one we're not really
very good at neutralizing or stopping
those strains even though it arose later
in the epidemic six months to eight
months later that really had more
emerged in humans and had adapted humans
so this idea of it's important vaccines
are critical they may be the most
important thing we can do right now um
but it's also possible that that they
may not work either now or for a very
long term so there's a possibility so
it's we need to have other modalities
second the time to develop vaccines
obviously differs from the trajectory of
the epidemic even almost optimistic
estimates think about 18 months to be
able to get something that could be made
and distribute it and have an impact on
yep
and that Universal vaccines against all
coronavirus groups will likely be
difficult or potentially a gaps or not
be possible so certainly there's some
possibility of broadly neutralising
monoclonal antibodies that could be
developed against the regions of the
corona virus spike protein that might be
broadly useful and on the shelf and
ready to try that's important that
should be done and that may be one of
most important things we can do but it's
also possible that it may not work so
this idea that if you could have broadly
active compounds that are targeting
conserved domains and the corona viruses
that you could have the potential for
off the shelf you store highly conserved
functions and that was really the goal
of our research that we wanted to do so
over our goal so what we're not if for
those of you who are on this on this
webinar that are looking at better drug
development people you will see that not
a single thing that I have on this slide
is really a classic drug development
goal because I'm not a drug development
person by background I'm a basic
biologist that really has been
interested in the converse replication
so but I'm also an infectious disease
physician and so my goals were those who
how do we think about this broadly to be
prepared so it's more about preparation
than it is about specific drug
development goals but our goals have
really been these issues of the idea of
having broadly active against diverse
coronaviruses so the idea we didn't want
a compound that worked well against one
human virus or SARS alone or MERS alone
those are important and those are
interesting for development but for the
purposes of what we wanted to target for
our goals they were to look at ones that
were active against diverse
coronaviruses second that they had a
high barrier to resistance because
antiviral resistance is something that
emerges rapidly viruses are very good at
this I'm not going to spend a lot of
time today I would like to if we had
longer to talk about the unique
superpowers of korone viruses in terms
of having the only virus family to have
RNA dependent RNA proofreading and the
capacity to limit access to that I'll
mention it briefly but so we were
looking for things that had a high
barrier to resistance those that had
limited genetic paths those that had a
high fitness cost in other words a
resistance arises that that would impact
the virus detrimental E
second that we could extend the
therapeutic window for prevention or
treatment when we think about influenza
and use with oseltamivir Tamiflu we know
that you have to tree within the first
24 to 48 hours to really have an impact
because of the development of late-stage
indices certainly this was important
with SARS models what we've tested the
lay diseases immuno pathologic right
there's a lot of interest in things like
il-6 inhibitors steroids other things
because this disease is an acute
respiratory distress syndrome a serious
illness of the lungs that is really
secondary to virus infection it's sort
of the equivalent of the body pouring
gasoline on a fire to try to put it out
and so you know if I think of an analogy
of if I fell in a fire and burned my arm
someone came along with a fire
extinguisher they could put out the fire
but they aren't gonna heal the burn on
my arm and I look I think a little bit
about this virus that way so if there's
things that we can do to lessen the fire
if there's things that we can do to
limit the damage that's been caused
along with therapeutic interventions we
can make a difference and then finally
are other things we can do to have
compounds that actually work in multiple
ways so they're not only treating
infection or lessening the severity of
disease but they also may be decreasing
transmission so is there something we
can do that will damage the virus in
such a way that the virus that is
released is less transmissible or less
infectious and those theoretically in
limited environment could have an effect
on local transmission of virus within a
family within a nursing home
within any another kind of environment
where there might be a high level of
high level exposure okay so I'm gonna
talk today really what I call
direct-acting antiviral so those are
things that are really you know for
treatment prophylaxis or transmission
prevention act directly on virus
replication in some way but prevention
of virus infection monoclonal antibodies
are and and host directed therapies are
profoundly important to us are vaccines
but that's not really my goal to talk
about those today you can get that
information from other places and
there's and there's other great
investigators but I want to take you now
briefly through the microRNA virus life
cycle and talk about a few of these
stages and spend a little time line the
grim rise replication cycle is like it's
in some ways it's
like every other RNA virus that is it's
an operative iris binds to receptors in
this case angiotensin converting enzyme
- is - the virus enters either by direct
fusion or by endocytosis we don't know
which this virus does yet many criminal
viruses can do both and that under
selective pressure they can change their
mode so that has some impact on how we
might think about blocking virus entry
once the virus enters the cell then the
next thing that happens is the viral
genome is released it's RNA it looks
like an mRNA it's translated into
proteins and those proteins are then
processed into individual proteins from
one very large replication poly protein
16 protein domains that are processed by
viral protease as' into individual
functions that function together to form
virus factories on host membranes those
membranes those factories then replicate
the viral RNA genome and and then they
replicate sub genomic RNAs that are used
for making structural proteins and those
all assemble in the ER GRC here are GIC
or golgi and then they are packaged and
released from the host cell most current
viruses can release a lot of virus
without every day without ever glassing
or damaging a cell so that's why they're
capable of really producing a tremendous
amount of virus burden because they
don't really immediately kill the cells
and so that they can generate a
tremendous amount of virus particles so
I'm not going to spend a lot of time
here because this really is getting it
but but there are targets of course the
spike glycoprotein which gives the Koren
virus its name on the crown of spikes on
the surface is a key target for is the
one responsible for host receptor
binding and entry determines the species
specificity tropism and immunity and
also the area where you have issues with
lack of cross protection because you
have variability between the spike its
receptors and it's it's it's proteins on
the surface it's epitopes of regions
that bind to those receptor I'm noticing
here I on the uncie matic on the right
the blue and green one of the spike you
can see that there is a little thing
called FP that's the fusion protein and
this is showing the fusion protein and
sort of it's pre fusion form which is
the form of the protein that is being
expressed in the moderna RNA vaccine
that's currently in trial the
this would be a ideally this form of the
spike protein would be a cute target for
vaccines to give a really good immune
response it might be protective and
might not cause any aberrant problems
okay so um the other place that people
are interested of course is ace
inhibitors that is those things that
might bind to the - ace - to angiotensin
converting enzyme - and compete with the
virus I think there are many of these
that are available that are used for
multiple functions and many of which
could be repurposed the challenge is
that they might not bind the same place
on ACE to as the virus does so trials
preliminary trials in our hands of a few
of these have been unsuccessful trials
elsewhere SARS were not very successful
and and I think they're worth trying but
I think that the data to date suggests
that they're not likely to be highly
highly efficacious but that remains to
be tested both in the lab and against
this received specific virus and
potentially in people if there's good
evidence that that's worth moving
forward
chloral and of course is getting a lot
of press I won't spend any time on it I
have opinions but I'm not going to share
them widely here it's a it there's not a
lot of data yet that it's directly
antiviral where it might be working is
that it acidifies endosomes and
potentially alters the internal
environment and blocks they're releasing
a virus from those cell I would like to
see specific data that looks really
carefully at this mechanism of action I
certainly think it's in it potentially
important as long as it's being tested
under controlled clinical trials and not
being used anecdotally or widely I think
there's a potential for significant harm
if it's not really tested carefully um
certainly there's at least one example
of with chikungunya virus where it
worked very well and be chode in fact I
think in primates or in in small animal
models but then in humans it really
caused a paradoxical effect with
enhanced replication and decreased
immune response against the virus so
there's no compound that they can't
cause problems and we need to look at
these really carefully so um
another another area that's been looked
at is is can we block entry of the virus
by blocking cleave cleavage of the spike
protein so there there are cleavages
multiple ones that occur that can occur
they can occur on the way in using
enzymes such as tempers to protease on
the way out
using furin this is certainly true for
multiple different coronaviruses and
that data will likely be emerging very
quickly in terms of what happens when
you inhibit those enzymes but one that
has been looked at and has been
published recently in cell was the use
of a compound that's been approved for
use in pancreatitis and into Japan
called chemists at missile-like which is
an inhibitor of the tempers two enzyme
and potentially is capable of blocking
virus entry by blocking that activation
of a spike glycoprotein on the way in
there are other Cal Cal pains can also
sometimes media this Khattab Tsin so
what other inhibitors of protein do
zonal proteases may also potentially be
effective at preventing virus entry and
replication from occurring another place
of course now what I mentioned is that
coronaviruses also synthesized or
translate from the genome a large
replicates poly protein with 16 protein
domains and it's like a string of pearls
on a chain one of those pearls on there
or two of those pearls have protease
activity and those two enzymes are
responsible for processing the viral the
viral polyprotein into its individual
proteins and mature proteins for
replication functions and I'm showing
here the schematic of the corona virus
replication Oh showing that what
occurred was called Wharf one a be the
the non structural proteins one through
sixteen all sort of synthesized as one
large or two large poly proteins and
then two protease is a little blue box
called peel pap pain like protease and a
little yellow box called 3c like
protease and then the big blue and
yellow boxes show the regions of the
replicates probably protein that are
processed by those proteases so so we
had data back in 1995 some of the very
first studies from my lab we're working
with protease inhibitors not for
therapeutic principles with Mouse
appetizers virus but to show that they
are required for virus replication and
you can profoundly
knock-down virus replication with
protease inhibitors because this process
of protein processing is required all
the time for the virus so theoretically
those are really good ideas and there
are some places that have been looked at
it so they never ton of ear is prettiest
inhibitor I think the data on that is
very soft I think a preliminary data
from that's well data has been published
by attempt Sheehan and it compares in a
comparison with room deseve or suggests
a limited activity to no activity of
LaPenta vir ritonavir in mouse models
mouse models of SARS one or murmurs and
so I think that the information for this
is not strong I think this should be
looked at carefully but I think it
should in detail the data should be
looked at it whether this was really an
active drug at all against SARS too
there are other protease inhibitors one
that's been used in cats and proved it's
used in cats widely and it's been able
to treat actually a chronic disease in
cats but no no known activity yet
against against this virus and I'm
certainly not being comprehensive here I
want to get on I want to get on and
spent the last 10 minutes or so thick
talking about what we're working at
which is really issues of corona virus
replication and viral replica RNA
synthesis with the replication protein
so that it can assemble and modify host
membranes and replication factories and
of course they have an RNA dependent RNA
polymerase think code their own
polymerase is one of these non
structural proteins that's highly
conserved across coronaviruses
preliminary is's are also RNA
polymerases are also conserved
structurally across really all RNA
viruses and they're similar to other
polymerases another in other species and
so certainly so what are the target as
targets well the targets for polymerase
inhibit inhibition of course are
nucleoside and base analogs that have
been efficacious antivirals against
multiple RNA in DNA virus polymerases
and there's some examples here for
different for different drugs
what are these well these are
essentially decoys they look like normal
nucleotides that would be incorporated
into RNA and then however they have
modifications that don't allow for they
either cause mutations to occur in the
genome or they terminate the RNA chain
as it's growing and blah
normal activity of the virus so we
wanted to look at these but what was the
challenge with coronaviruses well as I
mentioned the challenge is that when we
looked at these in the lab over many
different years we'd look a tribe of
iron because everybody wanted to use
rival iron for everything and we look at
other chemical model nucleoside
analogues that wouldn't be used in
humans like for this purpose like five
for uracil and what do we see so here's
what we see
the problem is corona viruses are
resistant to many of these basically if
you look at the the black lines across
the top these are essentially telling
you that there's no decrease in virus
titer no matter how much of these drugs
you give these viruses laugh at these
compounds the theoretical curves for
inhibition would be the you know the
sloping line showing what we'd like to
see so what why is this the case well in
fact we know why it's the case and the
reason is is that corona viruses are the
only known encode of proofreading
exonuclease this is a discovery in my
laboratory by let's accurately back in
in 2007 and we've studied these enzymes
in detail so these corona viruses
compared to other RNA viruses can do
proofreading and they can do error
checking okay from a during virus
replication so they can remove miss
incorporated nucleotides and they can
confirm very high replication fidelity
probably 20 times higher than other RNA
viruses so what we've done is when we
knock out that enzyme by putting
mutations and then genetically and
rescue these viruses we can get a virus
back that has makes more mistakes it has
a mutator phenotype and when we then go
back and test these same compounds with
the virus lacking exonuclease what we
find is it's now susceptible so in fact
it is possible for these kinds of ends
these kinds of drugs to inhibit grown
viruses you just got to get rid of the
exonuclease or you got to bypass it so
we asked the question is it possible to
have the nucleoside analogs can inhibit
corona viruses in the setting of a
proofreading exonuclease well that was a
question and so we started a
collaboration we started multiple ones
we've have two major ones that are
ongoing one is with Gilead Sciences and
the other is with the Emory Institute
for drug development and Emory
University to actually test this when
these were based on our really
interacting with them and identifying
them and having them willing to give us
compounds to test so this is just
showing the one with room desapear which
is the compound
is currently in trials really starting
back in 2014 where we demonstrated some
of its anti coronavirus activity and
then really up to February a now and the
the phase three trials began in China so
um I'm showing the two compounds here
lubed uh severe and beta D and four
hydroxy sided inor NHC and in showing
that these have what I would call that
that ideal curve right so you can see
that you get a decrease VTR means virus
titer reduction and and the numbers
negative zero through minus six indicate
log reductions so minus six would be a
millionfold reduction you can see with
increasing drug concentration you see a
decrease in virus titer that's log order
reductions milli up to million fold
reductions and these have very very low
effective concentration 50s sub subt
animal or right so these are sub
micromolar alone and molar
concentrations very effective inhibitors
which we are excited about and I'll tell
you we still don't know how they bypass
the proofreading and that's an exciting
biological question our laboratories
investigating how do these particular
compounds bypass block get by evade
overcome decoy how do they work because
the discovery for us is just as
important from a biological perspective
because it gives us clues about how we
could further inhibit other
coronaviruses if we understand how these
compounds work so the next step after
showing they worked against this and now
we're just gonna talk about REM desapear
is to test them against other
coronaviruses and this was done by Tim
Sheehan and Amy Simms in the barrack lab
at UNC where they basically tested this
against multiple corona viruses so you
know 63 is a normal human coronavirus
HKU five is a MERS like bat virus we
test them against merged and SARS as
well against a SARS like bacteria and
viruses and then circled in red or these
what we call pre-pandemic bat viruses
and you can see that basically the
curves are all that the slopes are all
the same increasing concentration log
order reduction in virus replication so
this gave us enthusiasm for potentially
working with these viruses so in the
ones filled in yellow are the ones that
have been tested we believe it would
work against all of them
actually and based on what we know and
and there is evidence in a Cell reports
China that a single figure preliminary
studies suggesting their ambassador is
working against ours copy two as well
and we have active studies ongoing
looking at the details of that and
really much more detailed in vitro and
animal studies to test and confirm that
of course um we're very hopeful that
this will be useful um humans aren't
mice sorry cubby two is not SARS or MERS
and the disease that we're experiencing
as a wide range of severity so at this
point we I don't have any data and then
no data available to me but I I
everything about it from a lab
perspective says that it has the
potential to work whether it works in
actual humans we remains to be seen and
I I can only be hopeful and optimistic
about that rather than having any data
so how different desapear work well it
acts as a chain terminator basically
incorporates into the growing RNA chain
is and then it basically acts like a
stop sign essentially blocks further
elongation so it's a very one molecule
goes in and that RNA chain stops so it's
very active that kind of absolute
selection would suggest that there might
be issues associated with with
resistance also and we also wanted to
know what happens with proofreading well
what turns out that actually if you get
rid of proofreading the the it's
actually more sensitive to the drug so
it actually is working it is blocking it
it's not blocking it completely but this
to us was exciting because it's the
virus the drug works very well but this
results suggest that if we could do
something to block the exit uh cliches
that in fact we might be able to really
increase the potency of these drugs and
some kind of combination form and not
really as an exciting prospect for us to
study so I'm not going to show you all
the animal data because I don't have
time but I wanted that to say that
studies done again in the Barrett lab
and published in 2017 apologized for
skipping the slides here decreases the
virus disease virus replication and
virus disease and lethal SARS mouse
model is an IV drug when it's
administered before or very
during infection it decreases virus
titer decreases weight loss decreases
lung pathology and improves lung
function all the above when it's when
it's given later an infection in mice so
that's really after two to three days
because the animal disease and SARS is
very accelerated the decreases virus
titer very effectively when given at any
time but it doesn't it decreased lung
disease from mortality this is what I
was mentioning earlier as we see with
other viruses whereas really
immunopathology was driving a late a
disease and so from the very early one
of our goals of course as I said to
extend the therapeutic window and the
question is are there host
immunomodulators that could be used I
would argue in combination with
direct-acting antiviral that would allow
you to use these drugs for longer
periods of time or in sicker patients
and have it and hope to have a better
outcome and I think that that's
something we're very interested in and
obviously we would have tested all of
that before the pandemic if the pandemic
had waited so um finally just a couple a
couple other points does it select for
resistance or what are the consequences
um so I say there's really two pieces of
good news one is it was really hard for
us to get resistance we had to coddle
the virus give it all of all the
niceness we could low doses of drug take
the drug away put the drug back give it
a day off all kinds of things before we
could get any resistance and we were
able to get some the other good news is
that resistance was limited it was like
less than six-fold so it was a really
limited resistance as you can see from
our passage 23 virus it was a little
less sensitive and we identified two
mutations that we identified that were
responsible in the viral polymerase
which is where we expected to see them
so the question was is these viruses
look like they grew pretty well so the
question was is how how good were they
how fit were they how much could they
compete with the wild type virus and um
what we showed here in brief summary is
two things on the Left panel is
basically showing that we took the
mutant the resistant virus and we took
the parent virus and we put them
together in host cells we took both of
them and we just let them compete and
then we took the competin competed cells
and we passage the virus from cell to
cell culture what we discovered and you
can see here is even when we give nine
times as much of the resistant virus
mixed with the wild type virus over
multiple paths
just the wildtype always one so this
resistant virus was actually weaker and
less fit and in animals on the right the
blue curve show a blue and red curve
show what happens when high dose is
given of either wild type virus or for
the mutant virus and the blue curve just
shows that the animals get less sick
they lose less weight and they recover
faster so this virus is also 10 you ated
so if you're if resistance arises it's
not competitive and it's likely to not
survive in the absence of the Chi of the
drug so so just to summarize just a
couple things one with whom death severe
is it really potent leontyev it's
multiple divergent coronaviruses very
well it is a high barrier to resistance
and it's detrimental to the virus it's
really useful for prophylaxis and mouse
model and for early treatment it's
likely less effective if it's going to
be used late and so that is implications
for how the trials are being conducted
and I hope and trust are being conducted
in the way that you can actually assess
its impact on earlier disease as well as
very late disease where people are
really having in stage a RDS finally the
green tabs on the right are basically
showing you that died this other
compound EAD D 1931 2801
or NH c is also meets all of these
criteria in our hands and and that and
that the the animal studies are in by
our archive from Tim Chien and UNC but
really all of our in vitro and in vivo
studies have demonstrated this virus
this drugs working is very well its
mechanism is different it's an RNA
mutagen meaning it incorporates and
causes mutations and causes the virus
essentially to mutagenize itself to
death that's a different mechanism and
we have evidence to suggest that these
viruses work in very different ways
which would which makes you think of
course of the kinds of things we've seen
with HIV which is treatment with
multiple different combinations of
either nucleoside analog inhibitors
protease inhibitors as combinations so
finally then come back into this issue
of the use of direct-acting antiviral
switch we've studied and will continue
to study we're very interested in this
parkland in a bit ritonavir that appear
there all of these compounds as well as
others that might arise and then to
begin to think of these in combinations
as monoclonal antibodies
to become on online very quickly to
begin to test specific monoclonal
antibodies in house directed therapies
and so with that I want to thank my team
and I want to thank all the people who
were actively treating these patients
here in Nashville and around the world
we're all in this together the only
event that I'm aware of in human history
that's affected the entire population of
the planet at one time it's serious we
need to be really dedicated to
continuing to find ways to try to
intervene in this and we are definitely
committed to that process and so I'm
happy to take any questions that you
might have
thank you mark thank you mark for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask the question box - located on the
far left of your screen okay let's get
started
we have so many great questions coming
in already mark what do you mind if I
pick a couple is that okay with you if I
sort of look at the interview if you
want to think that we don't know I was
gonna ask of you but go for it
absolutely um yeah if I may need help
there's a lot of good questions here um
um so a couple I think that came in
really really quickly are why are
children not getting a sick with this um
I'm an infectious disease person I've
watched this forever
I think about I think about this related
to other virus it's always best to use
models that the answer to almost
everything about this viruses we don't
know because we've never encountered
anything like this before I'm aware of
in human history okay where the entire
planet isn't immune susceptible and
that's a scary thing because it says a
lot about us not really understanding it
but with some models we can think about
with with children um and perhaps
they're better as evolutionary models
and they are as viral aaja chol models
there's there's many ways to propose why
kids don't aren't as frequently infected
or as
those could be that the receptor root
specificity is different that there's
developmental changes in the receptors
and how they occur on children that
their immune response is actually more
naive or less developed and so they
actually may have biological replication
but they didn't develop in the
immune-mediated diseases that's possible
I mean evolutionary perspective I guess
it's almost a tautology to say that in
fact they don't get sick because they
don't get sick in other words that over
time that human beings have been exposed
to so many serious viruses over time
that there had been a development of
essentially for survival of the species
you had to have children capable of
surviving to adulthood and so the
selection against a virus causing this
kind of lethality and children I say
that because there's models if you take
for example measles virus and you go to
an immune naive population like a
separate island somewhere and these have
been done have you seen this with other
diseases like smallpox and measles where
they entered into a particular place
like the Faroe Islands and what you saw
was the normal kind of childhood disease
and children but you saw profound or
leave their little severe disease and
adults who had never seen the virus as
children and so I like I said that's not
an explanation but that's sort of an
evolutionary model for how our long-term
battle with viruses over the course of
our evolution may have impacted how
what's going to happen to children when
they encounter these kind of new new
organisms and and pathogens I'm sorry I
was just gonna say that one of the
common questions I keep seeing in these
wonderful webinars today is whether or
not the blood type linked is a linked to
coronavirus infection and I see three
people have asked that question here for
you as well I think people are trying to
find is there a formula almost right um
my bet is that this this virus has our
number and that in theirs I think with
the diversity of what we're seeing I
would I would be profoundly surprised if
there was a single genetic determinants
there's there there's no sex racial
linkage now the numbers are large enough
that I believe will explain this I think
this is about the virus okay and about
me and potential about receptor
expression and then potential
variabilities that might occur in our
immune response certainly with some of
the viruses like norovirus and
everything for example blood type
specificity is important some people
don't get ill at all so I think that
that's a possibility and that's an
interesting idea to explore whether
there are you know of HLA types or blood
types that might be that might be
relevant that's an exciting research
question right now I didn't know data to
support what that one way or another and
another question I saw here was why the
human being is not encountered this type
of virus before in evolutionary history
it's the interaction with wild game was
even greater than currently i I would
argue it has I would argue we have
encountered these all the time and what
is is does it have all the capabilities
of maintaining itself in in our in our
population and transmitting so what's
changed what's different well I think in
the past if these encounter disease
might have been in a small village in a
small town before corona viruses are
known they might have stayed local they
might have been in the background of
other serious illnesses like that were
prominent and maybe now more vaccine
control like pneumococcus influenza
diphtheria you name it tuberculosis
other things and so the idea of a single
death from a pneumonia would never have
been identified or even a cluster or you
in a small village but those didn't have
what didn't they have well they didn't
have the capability to travel they
didn't have the capability for large
number of people clustered in major
urban centers they didn't they didn't
have time to develop other things the
other thing is I think this is maybe a
little bit about the virus it just about
the virus because there's not a lot of
doesn't not look like there's a lot of
selective pressure on this virus for
evolutionary or adaptive change it looks
pretty much ready to go it kind of came
out with his Swiss Army knife the tools
and it's ready to go and I think that's
different so once the encounter occurred
and the opportunity occurred that it was
human demographics human travel whether
that was in China or elsewhere that
allowed this virus to disseminate as
well as it sort of stealth mode
I had been argument from the very
beginning that this virus was likely
having a symptomatic of pre-symptomatic
transmission so all of those things may
be why this is sort of the perfect storm
that we have been worrying about I want
to pause and I want to thank the
audience because we have over 40
questions coming in and I know that
we're not going to have time to answer
all of them and I just want to remind
them that any question is not answered
today will be answered via email and I
noticed quite a few questions asking
about the ad detection about the sample
of choice and also about the procedures
in the testing maybe you want to touch
up on that baby um I could I'm not the
expert on that um I think the standard
tests that have been coming from the
from CDC here certainly have been based
on the nucleic acid gene so that's this
particular region of the genome that's
been identified I think that it's it has
been facility for sure and I think that
um you know in our hands or others that
the kind of assay has sensitivity
associated with it I'm not able I don't
have the data on denominators I also
don't have the data on controls positive
or negative so the issue I think in a
high prevalence time when you have a
setting where there's a high probability
of the infection being there that tests
like this can perform very well right
because you're like unlikely to have
false positives or false negatives
because if you have a consistent
syndrome or you have a population that's
highly exposed then you that that's
really not so much of the concern is if
you're looking for something really rare
in a population and your test may fail
so I don't have a lot of data on that I
probably can't go any further with that
but I have reasonable confidence that
these tests I have good confidence that
these tests are performing as advertised
um the rest of it's about the virus
again so um there are now data coming
out that PCR positivity may drop off
pretty rapidly in a real infection and
so it really depends as much on when you
get it and how fast you get it and if
you repeat it in certain circumstances
as it does with the ability of the test
I actually think the test is good I
think it's the virus
showing the variability mm-hmm is there
any indication on how often the virus
mutates is it similar to the flu
mutation so there's not a lot of data
for mutation and I think this is really
really important there's not a lot of
data for mutation yet I think the
pressure for me to win will the pressure
permutation arise and SARS that appeared
to happen pretty fast because it looked
like it was ping ponging back and forth
between human and civets okay and and
other animal factors until it finally
adapted to humans and then there was
adaptation to him in humans with other
changes that had to do with its binding
to the ACE to ace to this virus has and
I and I am not up-to-date on the
thousands of no specimens available so
that please take this as a caveat but I
it doesn't look like it's doing that yet
when will that pressure if it's not
doing that yet when will that pressure
rise that pressure may not arise until
you have a substantial amount of the
info people have been vaccinated or that
you have a substantial number of people
who had natural disease and now have
some existing immunity then there will
be selective pressure on the virus for
change until then it doesn't look like
it's under a lot of selective pressure
which is scary I think because it means
that it's capable of moving through
population without having to really
adapt as it goes the only advantage of
that is that that means that vaccines
that might be developed now might be in
a position to to go against all of the
potential viruses that are out there but
people are talking about circulating
strains I think that that's not as
that's not as accurate a phrase as I
called them of polymorphisms about
polymorphisms because those don't appear
to be really impacting this disease of
the virus so far or a probability that a
vaccine has developed a single type of
vaccine this develop would be useful I
think I think about some more like
measles where there might be some
variations that occur but the vaccine
still works at least initially what is
what interesting questions coming in
estrogens helps with immunology
protection could this be why there is a
difference between men and women with
their severe
action rate I haven't seen the numbers I
was unaware that there's like there may
be there may be some isolated things in
terms of severity of disease that you
know some of these can be masked to be
wrong for example with MERS or definite
was a sex distribution with more men but
that also had to do with the fact that
men were more likely to be around camels
right so there was something there was
said there was some abnormal there were
some things that looked like they were
sex differences but really weren't they
were more about exposure differences so
my hypothesis would be that we're
actually not going to see sex
differences in severe disease um we
might we might find out there's more to
do with pre-existing conditions other
underlying conditions this is the
challenge of really getting good enough
epidemiology I wanted to answer if I
could the science question again at
least one person asked me a question
about a Rinda severe gets incorporated
during replication it adds three bases
and replication terminates that would
explain how it gets around the
exonuclease can you comment on this so
thank you thank you viral geeks I like I
like those questions right in my
ballpark I'm the point here is what they
said is I my model showed that it
incorporates in the RNA chain and it
terminates that would be called an
obligate chain terminator meaning it has
to stop right away of this question this
person is absolutely correct that this
probably incorporates the nucleoside and
then it adds three more bases and then
it terminates so it's called a non
obligatory nater which sounds like a
oxymoron that is one possibility from
how it gets by the exonuclease because
that if it's a nucleus is always
checking for mistakes if it's checking
right as it gets incorporated if the
thing has already moved on three bases
that it might not know it's there so
coronaviruses might not have the
capacity and it's an excellent question
and i think we'll go back and look at
that in more detail there are
biochemical models coming online but
this is really important because if
we're gonna develop multiple compounds
that are effective against all
coronaviruses this one and going forward
that we need to have that kind of
understanding of details of the biology
absolutely and one another question
could you elaborate if possible is on
the COBE being airborne
temperatures the country for example
this particular audience number is in
the Caribbean yeah so um this comes to
this issue of seasonality you know I'd
like to say viruses um especially our
viruses aren't seasonal they're
migratory they appear seasonal Duras
because we're where it's sent where
hemisphere centric right
and so flu what you think about it we're
always picking the flu vaccine based on
different for the North America we're
taking the flu vaccine by what's going
on Australia or China or elsewhere in
the world right and the other and the
other seasons and that's true of
seasonal coronaviruses the Traverse
Victoria and social virus these are
viruses that seem to migrate and but in
the tropics they tend to not be seasonal
they tend to be low level endemic
year-round not necessarily causing the
peaks of epidemic height but kind of
consistently present the concept as
virus will become a seasonal virus maybe
happen in a year it may take a thousand
years before it becomes a seasonal virus
as long as we have a significantly
immune naive population
I would hope that's not the case but
it's already in the tropics it's already
in the southern hemisphere and so
viruses like humidity in certainly in
the lab they like humidity and
temperature they like 37 degrees
centigrade and they like a lot sea
humidity they grow very well and they
survive a long time in those kind of
environments when you get a certain
temperature they become more labile and
damaged more easily um but I think it's
much more complex than that it has to do
with all kinds of materials there in
what their stability is on environmental
surfaces what's the difference between
saliva and nasal secretions and blood
and you know sputum and different things
like that I've can they be airborne I
think the data coming out suggest that
they can survive as airborne small
particles for multiple hours I don't
think they'll ever be considered like
measles or chicken pox where if you're
in a room two hours after someone's been
in there with those diseases you could
still get it but not like that and
they're not like TV but but can there be
transmission by airborne roots at this
point I think the data suggests yes
I have one what are you testing right
now we're testing the compounds that
we've already tested NHC and Renault
severe we are certainly looking at other
combinations we're very interested in
Proteus inhibitors work of multiple
kinds we're really interested in novel
mechanisms that might affect virus entry
or virus exit there are multiple other
protein proteins that are the virus
replicas makes they make a polymerase an
exonuclease a helicase ATPase they make
multiple process civet e factors and RNA
binding proteins we're interested enough
in screening but we're really interested
in targeting those kind of enzymes as
well certainly we're interested in
targeting the exonuclease so um you know
if you ask me what's one of the most
important things to do to do this I
would say maintain programs and build up
manpower of people and in young
investigators who can be supported to do
this kind of work we have a small lab we
have five or six people who can do this
little work at bsl-3 it takes a long
time to train people for this kind of
work to do it safely effectively so this
is a limiting resource we are a we are a
genetic bottleneck to management and
treatment to testing against the virus
us and a few other people well I think
this points out the need to continue to
prepare like we've been trying to
prepare for the viruses that come along
right now thank you very much can we
have time for a couple more questions
how can we choose specific molecular
tests from the ones available from
different countries I think this is
another diagnostic question about what
kind of test we want to use I think the
idea is we want to develop multiple ones
for example so example I had a question
from someone today who had been infected
and they want to know so what's what's
my probability now that I and my family
have been infected and I think my kids
are infected my wife and we're all
recovered you know can we be with people
who are ill can we be caregivers for
those people for their children now that
multiple families are involved can we be
around them and are we safe or are we
gonna get reinfected and maybe we won't
get ill but we'll be transmitting virus
and the point is that we need to have an
initial test that rapidly art can be
used for both diagnosis and for answer
for surveillance in epidemiology
second we need to have tests that can
allow us to understand how are people
protected sociological test to say does
their immune response are there their
secretory IgA their circulating IgM and
IgG are those neutralizing do they kill
the virus and are those people actually
protected from reinfection likely to be
protected from reinfection what's that
going to look like
Karuna viruses are out of the bad news
for corona viruses is that that immunity
does not appear to be highly durable
that is I can get a respiratory virus
and you're one another one in your two
but I can get pay again in your three
it's usually milder it's not a severe
depend I think it probably has some
protective effect but it's not a hundred
percent well it's important for a
disease like this because you don't want
to be in position I'm not being ill but
having the virus and shutting it to
someone else and maintaining the
epidemic thank you so much dr. Denison
and again I want to remind everyone that
any questions not answered today will be
answered via email did you want to
provide our audience members with any
closing remarks I think we're all in
this episode there I'm afraid I've I'm
possibly my age and possibly working
with these viruses for so long I think
we're all in this together
and that we have to have these multiple
modalities we have to not be just
thinking about now but the future I
think this virus is with us for some
time to come and implications are
profound um I'm interested in in talking
people about this and and mechanisms
that we could use to have combinations
of therapy for if you want to lobby the
NIH or others for the need to get
manpower both in the in the treatment
but also in the research components of
this I would be happy to chat with you
about it thank you and thank you again
for your time today and for your
important research and before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us and again we're
interesting questions questions we
didn't have time today will be submitted
on you can submit on demand and will be
addressed by the speaker via your
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and a reminder this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
the end of the year 2020
batteries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share your email with your
colleagues who have a miss today's live
event until next time bye bye and please
be safe and healthy take care everyone
okay